CNN the one-time News Network known as
CNN they're starting to freak out
because people are finding out the truth
so CNN is talking about possibly leaving
Twitter I think this raises a big
question about what the Free Press what
the future the Free Press on Twitter
looks like you know our news
organizations going to stand by as the
reporters are just you know hastily
banned without explanation uh CNN is
saying it's going to reevaluate its
relationship with Twitter based on the
response it gets I want to read you the
full statement Allison it says
um
the impulsive and unjustified suspension
of a number of reporters including CNN's
donio Sullivan is concerning but not
surprising and it goes on to say
Twitter's increasing instability in
volatility volatility
should have should be of incredible
concern for everyone who uses Twitter
and then it goes on to say we've asked
Twitter for an explanation and we will
reevaluate our relationship based on
that response and I think it's so
important to point out that Twitter
really needs or really relies on news I
mean that's what's the kind of the
lifeblood
no lady Twitter does not rely on
journalists you guys have been the prime
purveyors of all the lies and what
you're upset about now is that other
people have blue checks and everyone's
got one of these and that means that
they can be journalists because they can
expose you guys when you selectively
edit the news you guys have lied CNN has
lied about everything I do this all the
time we can go through it very fine
people on both sides Brett Kavanaugh has
a serial rapist Jessie Smollett got hung
with the after eating at Subway all of
the lies right so they've like coveted
all the coveted stuff it's all you guys
get all of it CNN has done all of that
so if CNN was to leave Twitter I think
that would be an incredible win and an
incredible blow against misinformation
right of CNN and that clown out Oliver
Darcy and the rest of those panelists if
they got off Twitter and again they're
referencing what they're referencing is
Elon Banning temporarily a journalist
for having doxxed him that's what
they're referencing he didn't ban
somebody because they said Elon Musk is
a mean dude okay these are the very same
people who of course I don't need
Phoenix to Google it for me this time
did not say a word when Dr Robert Malone
and Jordan Peterson and James Lindsay
and everybody else was suspended so the
shoe is on the other foot and these
people are suddenly realizing what
principles are but dare I say it's a bit
too late